writers have to write whether they want
to or not whatever is lurking deep
within their souls has a mind of its own
spewing out words that delight us or
make us cringe in horror you said
something about this at the Bombeck
Writers Workshop keynote you didn't 2014
correct you talked about that why do
writers have to write I guess it's in
you and somebody made this comment to me
the other day they said we were you know
because I've been doing novels and now
this new book and they said you know we
really admire that you're still doing
this and I said well I just do it I do
it because it's what I do and and but
I've always been the kind of person and
one of the reasons that in a way I was
happy to get away from sitcom is that I
think when I feel like I don't have
anything more to say I'll probably stop
writing but as long as you have some
idea in you that you feel is worthy then
you want to do it and in this particular
book I have one essay in this place I'll
hold it up one more time the way we the
way we work and in this book this book
has 41 contributors talking about their
Hollywood experiences so my contribution
I wrote one essay out of the 41 and
there are many people in this book who
are far more famous than I am
but my essay is about working in sitcoms
and having to basically kind of like put
your writers voice on hold because when
you work on somebody else's show like
home improvement that is the creator's
voice and Tim Allen's voice it's not you
so you become sort of an imitator a
mimic you got to write this show kind of
the best way it can be written like in a
way like it's been written before put
your own little spin on it but it's not
you so I'm at the point in life
being writer where I get to write what I
want to write and and I won't I don't
think I want to write if I don't feel I
have anything worth writing about
you had a long career in television then
you write two novels that are about sort
of anti-heroes that are questioning
right the American dream correct why why
write about that um I guess well first
of all when I wrote the first one I
didn't really know whether I was capable
of writing a novel and I just came up
with this character who was about the
same age as I was um
guess who's early 50s or 50 and he's
questioning his life and he does not
want his life to go out the way it's
been going so far he's kind of been sort
of a loser for the two first two acts of
his life and he wants the third act to
be something you know that's worthy that
he could be proud of so I I didn't
really know this at the time but I mean
I knew that I was looking to do
something new my life had been my
working life had been successful but
like the main character I wanted my next
act to be something different I didn't
quite know what it was so as I wrote
this character you know the character
started off as a loser and his problems
were different than my problems but as I
got through the plot of the the book the
character and I shared a lot of similar
things so it was really an amazing
writing experience from that point of
view and then with cascade falls you
have it where the characters sort of up
against the the shadow of his successful
father absolutely right so that dream
also starts in Hollywood that bet it's
about I was really curious about this
what happens to those people who have a
Hollywood dream and then get involved
you know they have a relationship
because they want to have somebody get
married and then they have kids but that
dream doesn't work out so what happens
to their life when they have to go to
plan B and what happens when they go to
plan B and they're not happy with Plan B
and Plan B has made makes them miserable
but yet they've already taken this step
into marriage and parenting how do they
how do they deal with that so you know I
saw people around me who you know they
were they thought they were gonna be
really really successful and they
weren't and they were and now they were
married now they had kids and what were
their lives like and how do you make
those lives good and and how do you be
happy with who you are so there were so
many interesting questions to explore
there what do you think it is that the
people because I've seen people that
seem out really very successful they
don't think they are I know two
different people I heard say oh yeah
well we had to take our kids out of
private school and it was like this
dreadful thing it was like they had
failed in life when most people it's not
even a matter of being able to put them
in private school what do you think
people see their lives as failures
because they're not on the cover of
variety well thank you la you're always
I mean I mean it's so obvious and the
way the world is becoming the the gap
between the haves and the have-nots is
getting bigger and bigger and you know
in a city like LA which does have a lot
of problems with its public schools and
people see their friends being able to
put their kids in private schools and
they they want to do that as well and
then it becomes kind of a thing that
well now I can't do that anymore so I
must be a failure and they're not
failures they're just they're just
breaking people is it okay to be you I
mean did you get to a point where you
said I want to be doing fun stuff I want
to be doing stuff that fulfills me and
whether now I can walk into a room and
people are gonna really want to perk up
and hear what I do
[Music]
versus me feeling fulfilled and maybe no
one's heard of it it's more important to
me did you get to a point in your life
where some of that didn't matter anymore
of people of people sort of the the
outward Hollywood success did you get to
a point oh yeah definitely it made more
sense for Bruce to be happy no
absolutely and I was forced into that
situation well first of all you know I
had done well and then my first wife
passed away so I had I had to take care
of my children so that kind of
eye-opener you know that changes things
in a hurry and you get your priorities
straight
in a hurry and as I was working through
that you know I had to think about
what's the next step of my ever am I
gonna go back and write and I took time
off and then when I was ready to write
again I didn't want to write sitcoms
anymore I mean I did a couple of things
a couple of pilots and I was just he was
not a fun experience and that's when I
got into the novel ready and why did you
want to do this book because it's not a
novel it's more of a Q&A this book I
want to do because I got sick of sitting
alone in a room and I was alone in the
room when I did this too but the
difference was I had to work with other
people I had to get other people to
agree to be in this thing and then I had
to do the work of editing their work and
it was really fun it was really fun to
do to do something different that it
wasn't all about me you know there are a
lot of people who work in Hollywood
I mean people similar to to my level who
write their own memoir for me I would
never do that because I mean my I've had
some interesting things happen in my
life especially you know with my wife
and all that stuff but I just I'm not
the kind of person who would feel
comfortable writing a 300 page memoir
about me it's not not my thing so it was
really wonderful to be able to do all
these little mini memoirs of people who
also like meet me maybe they don't feel
like they want to write a whole memoir
about them
they don't have a whole memoirs worth of
stories but everybody has a story to
tell and it was great to be able to
include these people especially the
below-the-line people who never get to
talk about what they do I have a hair
stylist and makeup artist I have an
animal trainer talking about her job and
it was wonderful because these people
never get their voices heard so he was a
great project from that point of view so
he got out of being alone in the room
for a while to interviews people did you
learn anything about yourself not just
like so-and-so work with this star and
this person and but I mean in terms of
did you see similarity with all the
writers and yourself yeah I mean a lot
of the writers and I kind of knew this
that all the writers have been through
certain struggles with their shows and
but you know you hear everybody else's
point of view and everybody else is
individual story and it just it
resonates for you it's not yours
necessarily but you relate to it in a
way that you go ah yeah I can see that
so it was wonderful to hear other
people's points of view
you